foreign
Philadelphia we were born and raised and
Kelly spent most of her days on the
playground let's talk to Sarah what's up
Sarah
hey how are we doing what are you doing
I'm partying man what are you doing what
the heck I'm I'm
incredibly honored to be on your show
well I am honored that you are giving us
your most precious resource which is
your time and you could be doing so many
other fun things this morning
so you know
oh no
did we used to date or something I'm
that's my like biggest fear that an old
girlfriend's gonna call and be like you
were mean
no no not even
even
um you were like I would never date you
all right so what do you got
so I felt like I can't be the only one
who gets triggered from listening to
your shows no everybody does I get
triggered sitting in here hahaha
what do you get triggered about
seriously like like every time somebody
calls in with
um
a marriage question infidelity question
I like project that onto my husband and
we get in a fight like I'm triggered
physically mentally everything
by these shows and
it started way back when you did your I
think it was your first marriage and
money show with Rachel yep Rachel my
good friend yeah yeah and I
person you should come y'all should
y'all should come and you can be
triggered for like 36 straight hours
[Laughter]
no kidding I probably would be but I was
like I don't like that guy have you been
cheated on before
yeah
oh well of course you see the
correlation right
I guess I do I just like I feel like I
should be over it like I should be okay
like it's my problem now
it is but I don't like to use should in
this situation okay I let's use a
different word because should has it
just often makes our bodies go into
defense mechanisms really somewhat
unconsciously so when someone's like you
shoulda bam I instantly have to protect
and defend myself now instead of
actually get to the problem okay
um should is often a shutdown word
doesn't mean that there aren't tons of
things that we should do I should take
care of my kids I shouldn't cheat on my
life all those things are true but when
I'm trying to get to the bottom of why
my body is responding in a certain way
that word's often not helpful so okay
think of it this way
um
and I want you to take full ownership
and responsibility and it sounds like
you're more than willing to do that
you're really trying to figure out why
can't you just listen to
this goofball podcast
without your body taken off on you right
so let me ask you this question
are you still in relationship with the
person who cheated on you
yes okay
so
what is your body getting out of the
response it's providing you when you
listen to this show
your body's trying to protect you from
what
yeah from being a fool okay so that's
one of two things either you have made
an identity
out of a person who was cheated on
that's become the way you see yourself
and when when somebody cheats on us two
things happen one we have that that
relational violation right this Core US
is broken and we lose trust in ourselves
because we should have seen it we should
have known I should have said something
earlier when I had an inkling and we
didn't we just lose trust in ourselves
and that's unmooring right
yeah so
that can be one the other is
your body recognizes very similar
patterns over the last year or two
30 years no no I'm saying your body is
picking up on this thing may be going on
again
yeah
and so do you think this has become an
identity for you it's just kind of the
way you see the world
or are you having to wrestle with at a
at a scary scary level because you
probably made some promises to yourself
the last time
is your body picking up uh there's some
similar patterns here I remember I
remember this story from last time
yeah that's a great question
um because I'm a six on the aces
okay and my husband's a six on the aces
so you've got two very highly highly
tuned Radars pinging off each other all
the time right
yeah always yeah
so
um
the thing is it's like the red flags
were there right now
no not anymore like I I point blank at
some this morning I said Dr John's gonna
ask me
if I trust you like a hundred percent
and he you know without even
finishing the sentence he said yes you
can trust me 100 percent
he even prayed he prayed with me before
this meeting
um
so that is a very different question
than
have you cheated on me again
right
it's a very different question and it's
an evasive question that we often ask to
keep ourselves safe from the truth right
so let's pretend that your husband's
been perfect he screwed up
um
what was the nature of the infidelity by
the way
with
um customers
okay
um how long ago
D-Day was three years ago and we've been
we were married 27 years when I found
out how long was it going on before that
seven years if not more okay
and you
in retrospect do you see where you
missed it or was this just a total shell
shock
um I feel like I didn't miss it I
was led to believe that I was crazy yeah
were you let me ask that's a probably a
better way were you roundly deceived
or did you choose to not know
probably chose to not know okay all
right
because because one of those there's a
there's a level of pathology so here's
for for everybody listening and for use
here here's one here's what I'm getting
at
um
Affairs happen one night stands happen
go into a work conference and you meet
somebody and y'all start laughing and
one thing leads to another that happens
or
texting back and forth with a workmate
that leads to this at least this that
happens okay
and I'm not saying it's right my thing
is good I'm saying it happens and I've
got empathy for that situation I
understand it
okay if that leads to
significant dishonesty gaslighting why
are you can't trust me this is your
fault you never trusted anybody you've
been doing this since we were dating
and it leads to these giant cover-ups
well now we have another layer as far as
I'm concerned
okay
um and that layer of not only did I
do something outside of my value system
but now I'm going to just intentionally
destroy somebody else to prop it up and
keep it going
those are two separate issues to me and
as far as I'm concerned I may be wrong
here and that's fine if I am one is
infinitely more nefarious than the other
sure okay
and the the the other option is there's
this going on your husband's a natural
flirt he's always clicking out of the
computer whenever you come home the he's
the the search history is always deleted
when you pick it up even over something
silly like just checking movie times or
something
and that nagging feeling inside like oh
he is always flirting with those
customers a lot right and you choose to
not ask
there's a participation there right it's
not that he's hiding anything it's just
all right I was gonna keep my head down
and we're just gonna keep doing this
thing and so it could be a mix of any of
all that all that to say is
when you listen to my show and we're
talking we're having
real couples going through real hard
things right now
and real individuals wrestling with
infidelity and with trust and with all
those things
your body's response tells me that you
haven't fully either grieved it you
haven't fully owned it
and that it is still a way that you are
viewing the world it's still the the
glasses that you wear
sure
yeah that makes sense
then the two questions so that leaves me
with two questions for you one why
listen to the show like stop listening
stop listening it's like man every time
I touch the stove it burns my hand or
keep listening to the show and choose to
enter into a really difficult season of
healing because I don't know that you're
there yet
yeah I don't think I am either so why
have you chosen to not enter into that
what what are you getting by hanging on
to this thing you know that safety that
feeling of safety
yeah
I just feel like I'm I'm waiting for the
other shoe to drop every day
what does your husband say when you tell
him that
he says he understands but
he's faithful like he gets it now like
he wasn't always empathetic
um
but he says I can trust him what have
you asked him to do to prove to
demonstrate trust not to just say it
what have you asked him to do what
behaviors are different now
I asked him to cherish me
um
he's not very good at that I've asked
him
what is cherish what what does cherish
you mean
um to think about me when I'm not around
how does he demonstrate that to you
to bring me something that means he was
thinking of me okay you want him to buy
you stuff
yeah or I don't know just anything write
me a note something that makes me
believe that he was thinking about me
okay
be affectionate with you be flirt with
you the way he flirts with customers
so you don't always have I know it
doesn't I can hear your voice yeah and
what you haven't done
you haven't said
I want you to give up your cell phone
and get a flip phone
what you haven't said is I'm gonna start
seeing customers not you I don't know if
y'all are a family business I'm making
something up
I want you to consider another line of
work
because when you go off to see clients I
still can't breathe
right what you've asked him to do is
something on the periphery and I'm going
to say this with all due respect and
kindness and love to him and to you
I'll buy you stuff that's fine and I
will hold your hand when we're watching
TV
that has nothing to do with my
extracurricular affairs
hmm
and so what you're asking him to do or
two to and what your body's demanding
are two different things
gotcha you're asking to be cherished
like
the object of his
um
pornography you're asking to be you're
asking to for him to replace flirting
with customers and being inappropriate
with customers and pornography with you
right and that's not the issue my my
guess is
he doesn't feel alive in his own home
and he's going looking for it
and that is a that is a relational
fracture that y'all gotta deal with I'm
not blaming you for that at all what I'm
saying is
his heart starts beating a little bit
faster when he's on the computer his
heart starts beating a lot faster when
he's flirting with somebody that's not
you
right and his heart slows down and goes
when he walks in his own front door
right and that's a choice he's made for
30 freaking years
right and then y'all have done that
dance together see what I'm saying
yeah
and so it doesn't surprise me at all
that you hear or see these relationship
challenges that your body is like this
is it this is it right here in our house
there it is and yeah
you're it just starts going on and on
and on right the Alarm Systems sound
what ails me
truth
I don't know that y'all have done the
work after what happened
okay I'll just cut to it I think you
think other things happened
and you haven't full you still don't
believe him is what I think
and you all have moved on down the road
and he's just trying to get quote
unquote back to the way things were and
you haven't fully let him know that
there will never be a going back
that what y'all had for 30 years is over
now and if y'all are gonna do anything
you got to build something new going
forward you haven't told him that
and you still think he hasn't told you
everything about what happened and you
haven't given him a path for regaining
trust in your home so if nothing did
happen
he doesn't have a way to show you that
he just has to keep saying it over and
over again and he's told you things for
30 years
right
so you see there's where there's just it
just gets in a figure eight Loop over
and over and over
yes and then eventually he's going to
get tired of coming home
and expecting you to read his mind
mm-hmm
I'm sorry expecting him to read your
mind
right and right
then somebody's gonna make him laugh and
now we're off to the races again
or about he's gonna send him a funny
email that's not so funny that's
he's gonna be down a rabbit hole again
this isn't your fault I don't want you
to hear me say that in any shape form or
fashion he's got a ton of work to do and
and man I wish he'd call into the show
because I would tell him he needs to be
shut his mouth and start acting
differently and he's not doing that
right
but I think you all got to get to the
core healing here because you just
aren't there yet that's that's what I
think I could be out to lunch but that's
what it sounds like to me
no I think you hit the nail on the head
I'm sorry I wish I was wrong I wish I
was wrong
oh good this is a Divine appointment I
was praying for
um
I wish that I wish that Divine could
have been kinder to to both of us
so here's the path forward
you have to own reality you have to
choose reality and I don't think you're
there yet
so
often when folks get stuck and they are
in this Loop like you all are in
and I say this over and over and over on
this show I think it starts with a
letter
that you end up reading to him
and in the letter you got to be honest
if you still don't trust him if you
think he had an affair wasn't just
contained in pornography or in being
inappropriate as you said
if you think he did other things
you have to ask Point Blank
write that in the letter I still am
unable to trust you my body is still
telling me you're not safe
you have to give him a road map that of
your choosing
back to not back to to a new level of
trust somewhere
what would that look like what does he
need to do to earn that trust and then
he is a grown-up just to make a choice
I'm not doing that I'm out or I'll do
anything in the world
to show you that I'm working on I'm
changing it could be marriage counseling
it could be getting rid of the phones it
could be no more computer access
whatever the things how crazy is is you
is you want to get it's up to you
and then you all have to decide
how do we recreate life inside this
house
what do I need to do to help you feel
alive and what does he need to do to
help you feel alive you've told him I
want you to cherish me I want you to buy
me gifts I want you to think about me
he needs to be able to say I need this
and I need this and I need this and then
y'all spend the next 60 90 120 days two
three four months
practicing meeting each other's needs
and meeting each other's needs all with
a goal of re-earning this trust back
building something completely new
but it has to start from a platform of
reality honesty truth
that's where we got to start Sarah
hang on the line I'm gonna send you a
copy of own your past change change your
future
um you can go through it and man you can
go through it with you and
um that can be something that unifies
you two together that you all use as
you'll begin to build something new give
me a call back I'll walk with you every
step of the way